هذه النظره شبيهه بتلك التي راقب فيها
منزله يتكون فوق عائلته اثناء الزلزال
حينها خرج من مشفاه فارا ليصدم بهول
المنظر لم يكن يسمح الوقت حينها للطبيب
عبد الباسط خليل ان يهرع لانقاذ زوجته
وطفلته الوحيده فالمشفى بدا يمتلئ
بالمصابين وقتها اختار ان يكون الطبيب
للزوج ولا الاب لشعور كتير صعب بس ننتقل
الانسانيه هي بتجبرك انه تساعد المصابين
ولو كان زوجتك وبنتك تحت الانقاذ بس ما
بيطلع بايدك شيء انت لم تسرق الكارثه
عائله الطبيب فحسب فمسقط راسه مدينه
الاتارب شمال حلب كانت احدى اكثر المدن
المتضرره بالزلزال وخساره مئات الارواح
ومع تجاوز عدد الضحايا في سوريا
3500 قتيل تنعكس صوره ما الت اليه الاوضاع
في المنطقه المنكوبه شمالي سوريا على
ملامح وجه الطبيب وصوته
الناس تعتبر ان الطبيب هو البطل في كل
مواقف وبينسوا انه هو انسان
متلون مثله وعنده عيله وعنده اطفال لم
ينفي عبد الباسط تعبه ومواجهه لكنه لم
ينفي ايضا ان الاطباء هنا قاوموا مشاعرهم
رغم حجم خسائرهم واصبحوا اليوم بحاجه لمن
يداويهم